what I like about IMAX is is because
it's taking up your entire field of view
you're actually choosing what to look at
so you could really zero in on an aspect
of the image that you're curious about
everything the light touches is all
kingdom there's a tremendous amount of
detail that's gone into this everything
has to be constructed by artists and
seeing in the large format you could
really see it vividly and all the
nuances you see every single hair you
see every leaf because the entire film
is set in either caves or exterior so
much of the experience is feeling the
environment around you and what the
sound design also associated with IMAX
you feel immersed in that
run away Simba and never return
be part of why people want to go to the
movies now is to is to have that
immersive experience the more of a
theatrical beautiful immersive
experience you have the more it entices
people to come out and enjoy it in that
traditional theater setting you have to
take your place as king the hard part
was the thing that we did that was new
that hadn't been done before which is
our style of virtual filmmaking where we
took the entire digital environment and
the animated digital characters and put
it into essentially a virtual reality
multiplayer game we were able to have
the entire crew come into a digital set
and Scout it and film it as though they
were on a real location so if you came
and visited us you would see what looks
like a functioning live-action film set
it starts to inherit the aesthetic of a
live-action production just the scale
and quality of the experience he had a
really bold vision for the movie
especially for Timon and Pumbaa which is
the keep our scenes very natural feeling
and very conversational and organic
within this big spectacle and and I
think you did a great job a lot of it is
is the translation of the performances
through the interpretation of the
animators using the body language or the
emotional language of each species it's
pretty epic just on a traditional screen
I mean it's shot and designed so
beautifully than an IMAX that's gonna be
pretty intense yeah will be funnier in
IMAX we're here Oh everyone calm down
we're here
you
you